MIKE XU: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our talk today.
We're going to be talking about
building data applications,
powered by Looker.
My is Mike Xu--
I'm an architect at Google.
I help our customers
design, architect and build
their applications using
the Looker platform.
And today, I'm also joined by
my friend and colleague, Nick.
NICK FOGLER: Hey everyone.
I'm Nick Fogler.
The founder and CEO
of 4 Mile Analytics.
And we're a strategic
Looker partner,
really specializing in the kind
of customer data experiences
built on top of
the Looker platform
features we'll be
talking about today.
MIKE XU: So for our
agenda in our talk today,
we're going to be covering
Looker as a platform--
all the different facets
of Looker's platform
to build your application.
And also, we're
going to be looking
at a case study of building
an application using one
of these facets,
which is the API,
for a global Fortune
100 retailer.
So Looker originally was built
as a business intelligence
and analytics tool for analysts,
marketers and product managers.
It has this really awesome
layer of technology
called Look ML, the Look
Modeling Language, which allows
you to express business logic.
And then your end users
can derive insights
from the data with
no code at all
so they don't need to
know SQL and they don't
need to run MAP-produced jobs.
So it's really evolved, now, to
become an extensible platform
to power other
applications so you
can get the richness of
every data source connected
to Looker that has Look
ML built on top of it.
You can also leverage Looker's
governance and security model,
as well as borrow from
its front end as well.
So we're not really
going to be talking
too much about Looker today--
there's plenty of content
out there available.
We're going to be primarily
focused on Looker's platform.
So there's three different
facets that Looker offers.
The embed and the API--
these are ways of getting
Looker into your application.
And the extension
framework is really
to change Looker so that way
it becomes more the application
that you want.
The Embedded Looker.
This is the way of getting
visual elements within Looker,
such as dashboards, or
explorers, or saved reports,
and you pluck that right
into your application.
If you don't like the way
that Lookers dashboards
or reports look, that's what
the API and SDK are for.
These are lower-level
building blocks
that we offer so you can build
a completely bespoke experience
from scratch.
And for a case study,
Nick will primarily
be focused on
looking at the API.
Finally, we have the
extension framework.
The extension
framework is, again,
to mold Looker to be
whatever you want,
whatever suits your data needs.
You can use your own
custom JavaScript directly
within Looker.
So let's dive into the first
facet of Looker's platform--
the Embedded Looker.
So here we have some
application code.
This is on your
server application.
It's actually one
of Looker's SDK's.
This is our JavaScript SDK.
We provide our SDK in
many different languages,
such as Java, Python, Go--
whatever you would like to use.
So the first thing we
need to do on our server
is to provide
which Looker server
we're going to request
the embed from, and also
the shared secret
to authenticate
our application to that Looker.
Once we've taken care of
the security configurations,
we can now define some
user context for our embed.
So the user context really
serves two different purposes.
First, we get end-to-end
tracing of that user
as they're using our native
application and Looker.
And secondly, we're also
tightly coupling the security
between the native
application and Looker.
We identified the user--
we can either use a single
sign-on service available
if we already have
that built out,
or we can just use the
native applications metadata
and provide some sort of
user ID to the Looker.
This context is also really
important to provide to Looker
because this is
what governs what
they can see in Looker
in terms of data
and also which
features in Looker
they have access to
within that embed.
Now we're going to switch
gears a little bit.
We're going to jump into the
front end of our application.
We're finally going to
instantiate our embed.
Once the embed is
instantiated, we
can couple that with
the native application
through the event bus.
In this example, we're modifying
which buttons are actually
driving the
dashboard's interaction
by binding listeners in our
native application on top
of Looker's embed.
So here's what it looks like.
We have our native application
outside of this red outline.
And within the red outline,
we have Embedded Looker.
You can see, if you're familiar
with Looker's dashboards,
this is just the themed
Looker dashboard.
But if you notice,
there's no filters--
like, you don't see
Looker's native filters.
We're actually
building the filters
outside within the native
application and coupling that
to the Looker embedded
dashboard through the event bus.
You can imagine how
this can rapidly
accelerate your
development of application
because you're not
really building
too much front-end code or
data visualization code.
So if you want
something different,
though-- like if our
dashboards or reports really
don't meet your
needs, that's really
when we start
recommending the API.
So here's our API
documentation page.
And you can see the large list
of different methods we offer.
These actually are the
methods that we use internally
to build Looker itself,
and we offer them to you
to build your applications.
So you have 100% coverage of
what Looker can do directly
through our API.
Here's an example of
an API application
that Nick has built
with his team at 4 Mile.
So again, if you're familiar
with Looker, right off the bat,
this looks like a native
explorer in Looker.
But this is actually
very different.
In this [? second ?]
application,
we're really building the
experience for the user
to be working with
different audience segments
and cohorts in mind.
So you're really just
comparing cohorts,
and looking at the
results between them,
instead of building these
complex filter groups.
Here we're building
out one of the cohorts
using the attributes available
within our user data set.
And once we've built out this
cohort, or multiple cohorts,
we can start doing
reporting against them
to search for outliers, or
maybe positive or negative
performances, within a
specific area of that cohort.
So, again, if you're familiar
with Looker's Query Builder,
this is a much lighter
weight and much more
custom-tailored experience
designed for marketers who
are focused on cohort research.
Here we have another
application that
was built on top of our API--
this was built for
global payments.
And this was a
merchant portal that
allows the merchants to see
their transactions over time.
So they can see each of their
given customers, what they're
making transactions
on, when they made it
and what kind of
metadata is associated
with those transactions.
We also have top-level reporting
to see, overall, the cash flow
throughout the day.
We're also going to be
diving more into the API
when we cover our case study.
Lastly, this is the newest facet
to Looker's platform, which
is the Extension framework.
So the Extension framework is
very different from the Embed
and API route.
Because you really don't
have to host anything--
you don't have any
application server yourself.
You don't have a
back-end or a front-end.
Looker is all of that.
So what you're doing is sending
us your custom JavaScript,
which will be encapsulated.
So that way your data
sources are still protected,
and also you're
Looker is protected.
But you're still able to
get the data experience
that you really want.
So here, this extension
was built by 4 Mile--
Nick's team, again.
If you notice, we are
still inside Looker--
we have the Looker
menu bar at the top.
But this is a highly
branded experience.
We've augmented Looker with the
user's native context in mind
to help them discover insights
and, hopefully, increase
action ability.
We're making Looker feel
more like home to them.
In this next dashboard, we're
overlaying multiple metrics.
So for this example, this
is a sportswear company,
and we're looking at how
weather is impacting the supply
chain in terms of orders and
dollar value to the business.
So, hopefully, you can see how
the Extension framework really
helps you build these
experiences that just having
tables and graphs
don't necessarily help
the users in drawing insights.
If you want something
really, really
custom or unique in
Looker, we encourage
using the Extension framework.
So if you're interested
in learning more about,
also, how other people are using
Looker as a platform, or more
about how other people are
using each of these facets,
there's lots of different
resources available.
First, there is a
Looker Blocks directory.
These are just code
examples, snippets,
that you can take and drop
right in your application.
We also have community
libraries, community tools,
such as linters,
stress testing tools.
And, finally, there's
LookML patterns.
So if you have a specific
type of data set,
we already have the best ways
of analyzing that data set--
and you can just
steal that from us.
So with that, I'm
going to turn it over
to Nick so that we can look at a
case study of actually building
an application on top
of the Looker platform.
NICK FOGLER: Thank
you so much, Mike.
So we at 4 Mile had
the great pleasure
of partnering with Mike
and his team over at Looker
recently on a
yearlong engagement
to build a large-scale
data application on top
of the Looker API for a
major global retailer.
And I'm super excited
to be here today
with you to share a little bit
about the underlying business
need that we are
trying to address,
the technical approach we
took and some of the outcomes.
So let's dive in.
Our starting point
on this engagement
was an internal
analytics application
that our customer
had previously built
whose goal is really
to serve metrics
to their retail merchants.
So the merchants
are the folks that
make key decisions
about what to stock
on the shelves, from
which vendors to purchase,
and how to price each item.
So really kind of foundational
stuff for any retail business.
At the scale that this
particular customer of ours
operates, pricing decisions
involving pennies either way
can have outcomes implications
in the millions of dollars.
So all of this decision-making
support is very strategic.
This application had
been in development
for about two years.
They had had about 100
people plus working on it.
And, generally,
the consensus was
that there was insufficient
level of engagement.
People just really weren't
adopting the application,
and the return on investment
just wasn't there.
Additionally, I think because of
the lack of speed and agility,
they were really focusing on a
one-size-fits-all all approach
to their analytics--
so it was very top down.
The bottom line was that
the application just really
wasn't keeping pace
with the analytic needs
of this organization.
And without access to timely
and relevant insights,
merchants were just
not really using data
to drive their decision-making.
So our mandate, if you
will, is to come in and just
highly accelerate the
delivery of the right insights
to the right people
at the right time--
and ultimately, to help
drive the fundamentals
of this business through data.
Broadly speaking, I
think any BI application
will be composed of a
couple of different layers.
On one hand, you'll have
a data back-end end,
typically consisting of
some kind of storage--
and a query engine
sitting on top of that.
And then you'll have
application code, which
serves to provide
a user interface,
and allow data exploration
and data visualizations.
We really saw opportunities
in both of these layers
to drive further acceleration.
On the data back-end
side, our customer
was using Thought
Spot, along with a very
manual and time-consuming
data engineering workflow.
And as a result when a
product person wanted
to publish a new insight,
it would take weeks,
and sometimes months, to
get that in front of users
to even find out if it had
any kind of business value.
So iteration cycles were
just taking way too long.
Looker talks about this
problem as the data bread lines
problem, in which you stand
in a queue for a long time
and you wait to get your
little nugget of wisdom.
And then having gotten
a little taste for it,
you now have to get back
in the back of the queue
and wait all over again.
The real wonder of data
analytics, in my opinion,
is that good answers
beget new questions.
And if your goal
really is to build
a data-driven
organization and culture,
your data stack needs
to be responsive to
this virtuous cycle of inquiry.
Looker is really built to
solve this exact problem--
it's kind of its core
value proposition.
And by adding Looker
to the stack, now
new questions can
be answered without
this big, long roundtrip of
moving and transforming data,
but rather with just simple
changes to Looker's data
model via LookML, which
Mike referred to earlier.
And those changes can be
done practically in real time
and by people with much less
technical sophistication.
So just by applying
Looker to the stack,
we brought a huge increase
in speed and flexibility.
On the application code
side, we replaced a lot
of verbose and poorly
encapsulated code
with an application development
toolkit that we built,
which gives engineers the
means to deliver new data
insights just an
order of magnitude
more quickly and with
a lot less complexity.
The toolkit offers a
high level of reusability
and a very clear
separation of concerns.
So, if you'll permit,
let's dive in one layer
deeper and just take a
closer look at the toolkit.
It's kind of composed
of two levels.
There's kind of a
back-end data service,
which is responsible for
proxy-ing API requests
to Looker.
And then, on the
front-end SDK side,
there are some capabilities
to build data visualizations
in a more kind of recurring way.
So we'll take a look at
each of those two in turn.
The architecture
of the application
is composed of a series
of microservices,
each really in charge of
their own area of concern.
So there's one that
does authentication,
there's another that does
logging, and there is also one,
of course, that surfaces
ThoughtSpot-backed data
to power front-end
visualizations.
We elected to integrate into
this existing architecture
by building a parallel
Looker-backed data service.
This had the huge
advantage of not really
requiring us to rip and replace
any part of the existing
architecture.
If we had done so,
it probably would
have brought product
development to a standstill,
and probably would have been
met with a lot of resistance,
let's say--
resistance to change.
So instead, we just built
this parallel service.
And without a lot of
fuss, we just started
doing it in a better, faster
way and let the results
speak for themselves.
In a pretty short
amount of time,
engineering teams
fairly organically
just started moving
over to using the Looker
data-backed service because
it just made their jobs easier
and allowed them to do a
lot more with a lot less.
The other really good
advantage about this kind
of data as a sidecar service
is that it exists somewhat
decoupled from the application
context in which it
was developed--
which means it can be
reused in a whole variety
of different ways.
We've essentially
built a capability
as much as we've built
a specific solution.
And the capability can
be used to, for example,
power other internal
applications,
or even externally-facing
applications that our customer
might want to monetize.
Given the constraints of
this particular enterprise
environment, our data service
wasn't built in the Cloud.
But it's important to note
that, in other circumstances,
you could use Cloud-based API
type services-- like Apigee,
for example--
to play the same role in
this kind of architecture.
So with that discussion
of the data service,
let's pivot a little bit and
talk about the development
toolkit that we
built that handles
the front-end visualizations.
For the front-end SDK, we
built a series of reusable
react components, each one
representing a different data
visualization type.
We developed the
interface you're
looking at here, which exposes
each of the different vis
components and acts kind
of like live documentation,
allowing developers,
and product owners,
and UX designers to
collaborate on the best way
to tell the given data story.
Anyone with access can
adjust the vis configuration
parameters to get
the vis just right
prior to committing any code.
We then connected these
components to the Looker data
service we just spoke about
and parameterized them such
that we can pass the ID of
any pre-built Looker query
object connected to the
vis, and essentially render
the results here in real time.
Once everybody's happy
with the results,
it's just a matter,
really, of copying
a couple of lines
of generated code
into the React
application code base.
So by way of both
the Lookup data
service we spoke about earlier
and this front-end SDK,
we've been able to leverage
existing capabilities
within Looker and build a
scalable architecture that
vastly accelerates
time-to-value for our customers,
while also decreasing
complexity.
The net result on
this engagement
has been a 10x
increase in the speed
it takes to publish new
insights in the application--
and all of that
with about a third
of the engineering
resources required.
So now, with relevant and timely
insights at their disposal,
these retail merchants
are using the application
in much higher numbers and
with much more regularity
than ever before.
So from a purely
quantitative perspective,
I think it's fair to say
achievement unlocked.
But honestly, the qualitative
outcomes of this engagement,
to me, are even more exciting.
What we delivered
initially was a series
of capabilities offering speed
and flexibility for the product
team and the engineering team.
But subsequently, we've
taken these same capabilities
and offered them to end
users, allowing them, really,
for the first time, to
self-service insights.
And as a result, the product has
moved from this very top down,
one-size-fits-all approach to
analytics to one that really
promotes much greater
data democratization--
and ultimately, better
decision-making throughout
the business.
The net result is
an organization much
better prepared to steer the
course through challenging
economic environments.
So that pretty much
wraps up what I want
to share about this engagement.
I do want to encourage you to
explore how Looker's platform
capabilities can transform your
own data culture and, in turn,
your business.
With that, I'm going to go
ahead and hand it back to Mike.
MIKE XU: All right.
Thank you, Nick, for that
walkthrough of the case study.
So I really hope this
talk gives you guys
a good sense of the Looker
platform's capabilities,
how it works and what
it can offer you.
Hopefully, you're imagining
how it can enable you
and your team to build
some really cool new data
experiences.
Developing with the
right tools can really
decrease the
complexity, and also
maintenance cost of
our rich applications.
And this helps us rapidly
build more and more powerful
applications as well.
It's important, really, to
note that Looker is really
just a piece of the tool set
within Google's development
environment.
In Google's ecosystem,
there are lots
of other tools designed
with developers
and their applications in mind.
Together, by using all
of these tools correctly,
you can really
accelerate development
and enable your ability
to deliver some custom
experiences.
Again, because we're freeing
up resources, or augmenting
our resources, this new
capacity allows us to really
innovate and make
groundbreaking business
discoveries for our end users.
If you're interested
in learning more,
here's some links to the
Looker platform and, of course,
also to 4 Mile so you can
see what Nick and his team
are up to and their projects.
With that, thanks so much for
coming to our talk, everyone.
NICK FOGLER: Thank
you, everybody.